somebody's going to limit my travel it
should be a communist not not my own
government hi i'm tim cavanaugh a recent
TV
we're here with congressman Jeff Flake
Republican from Arizona and one of the
great voices for limited government in
Washington congressman great to have you
with it thanks for having me on you're
the former head of the Goldwater
Institute and as an Arizonan can we talk
a little bit about the legacy of Barry
and to what degree is current Arizona
politics and current Republican politics
nationwide infused with a Goldwater
spirit well certainly Arizona is I grew
up in northern Arizona rural Arizona the
town of snowflake five generations back
and so similar story to the Goldwater
family and there is a kind of a
libertarian certainly limited government
independent streak that runs through
Arizona certainly through rural Arizona
and old Arizona and I think Arizona
politics is still to some extent defined
by that late in Goldwater's career when
he sort of went liberal on some issues
equal treatment of gays and lesbians and
so forth that was viewed as a shift in
his thinking and I mean was that dude
did that really reveal a shift in his
thinking or was it really a shift that
had occurred in the Republican Party I
think there's some both to be frank I
think some of it some of his positions
you could ascribe to simply this is
traditional conservatism or classical
liberalism but but there were a few
nuances that were differences in I mean
direct difference from an opinion or a
position that he had held previously but
by and large I mean he was still defined
as a man that believes in limited
government economic freedom individual
liberty how much of day how much of this
is Arizona itself I mean the the climate
the the type of people who settle there
and so forth I think that there is there
is some of that and certainly we like to
think of ourselves that way
so yeah I think that's a good
description where do you put the current
Congress and the current actually
administration - on the the idea of
limited government how much of it is for
real how much of it is party politics
well if you look at both parties we've
both behaved rather horribly over the
past few decades if you just take
Republicans you know between the years
2000 and 2006 when we controlled both
chambers and the White House we behaved
very badly and I'd like to say you know
we were headed toward this fiscal cliff
that we're headed toward long before
Barack Obama took the wheel he simply
stepped on the accelerator quite a bit
and we're gonna get there a lot faster
but make no mistake we were headed there
and so we we didn't do Republicans have
deviated quite a bit from our limited
government roots and if you look at
those years when we controlled most of
the federal government that's a pretty
good indication of where we had gone to
we'd pretty much kind of run out of
ideas if you will at that point we'd
passed in the 90s the freedom to farm
act for example getting farmers on a
glide path away from subsidies in 2002
we passed the farm Security Act which
basically brought a lot of those
subsidies back and and really did what
you know the old rhetoric that Ronald
Reagan used to use freedom for security
we not only did that in practice but we
even gave away the rhetoric pass you
know replacing the freedom to farm act
with the Farm Security Act and and that
was just one example you had the
prescription drug benefit you had
bloated you know transportation bills
earmarking Donner Arai and it just
wasn't a good six years for us that
we've kind of hit the road to Damascus I
think after 2006 and elected a lot of
new freshmen in the Republican Party who
have turned things around a bit but
we'll see whether we're serious or how
serious we are in the coming weeks
coming months how much of this is
changing conversation like you know it's
it's still right
even now really hard to get the idea out
there that that all the spending is not
actually causing an economic recovery
and the argument that we you know of
whether we need to spur the economic
recovery first or pay off the deficit
first is a non argument how much of the
you know even the media coverage play
into that well it's it it's difficult I
mean we we say that in you know in our
rhetoric as Republicans will talk about
the failed stimulus and whatnot but then
when we put an appropriation bill that
basically takes us just back to 2008 or
at best maybe 2006 before the stimulus
before a lot of ramped up in spending
then we have a lot of Republicans
pulling back and saying we can't do that
because the economy needs this kind of
spending and so I'm not sure if we
believe our own rhetoric sometimes and
we will see in the coming weeks will
really know when we have to raise the
debt ceiling and we'll see how serious
we are about you know putting in place
some some things that will benefit us in
the long term
you mentioned earmark contained pork and
for a while there you were the hog
butcher to the world or the the great
face of anti earmark you know momentum
in the house what's come of that and
where where do we stand with that now
well that's that's that's one great
success I think that we've had over the
past few years earmarks represent only a
small a small part of the budget but
they affect the larger budget in ways
that people simply don't see when you
have an earmark in a bill then you tend
to support that bill no matter how
bloated it becomes and the horse-trading
log-rolling that goes on with earmarks
tends to blow the entire government and
and just the kind of the pernicious
nature of basically conceding that this
pot of federal money is needed for my
district or for this company or for this
nonprofit organization that you know any
right minded conservative would realize
you know that it's really not not good
for the federal government to be
spending in that way but you get caught
up in it as we did as Republicans
and it's tough to get away from but we
have and one of the first effects you
saw earlier this year when we passed the
the HR one the big continuing resolution
there were no earmarks in that bill none
and because there were none people
actually went to the House floor and one
votes on spending cuts like 49
amendments were passed that actually cut
spending and that would have been
unheard of just a few years ago and it
only happened because there was no log
rolling
there was no appropriate or looking at
you say you take this one down your
earmark will be taken out in Congress in
conference is there other stuff like
that you know Robert's Rules of Order
type things that you can do to kind of
you know cur
cut back some of the abuses yeah and
we're trying a lot of them some of us
I'm now on the Appropriations Committee
a surprise surprise and it's it's a bit
of a lonely experience there but but we
do what we can in ways that will raise
some of these issues publicly for
example within the farm bill we've
passed massive subsidies for cotton and
we subsidize cotton to the extent that
were we run afoul of our own
international trade agreements Brazil
sued in the WTO and won and so instead
of cutting down our own subsidies to our
own cotton farmers we've told Brazil
we'll pay you to subsidize your own
cotton if you don't pursue the case and
so for the past couple of years and for
the next you will be paying about 150
million dollars a year to Brazil to
subsidize their cotton so we can
subsidize our own and myself and and a
few other members decided to remove that
subsidy and committee and we were able
to do that because it's difficult to
defend that publicly the subsidy to
Brazil yes to Brazil
we're still subsidizing our own cotton
right but when we removed it in
committee then when it got to the floor
they used the same kind of rules that
you can get out of Robert's Rules of
Order or whatever and removed my
amendment that removed the subsidy and
so we had to do it again on the floor
but we were able to we'll see how far
that goes
because obviously this is just a house
version you've got to have the Senate
agree but for every person that uses the
rules to cut spending you will have
individuals use those same rules to put
that spending back so it's a bit of a
shell game
yeah you're speaking about trade and
you've been a big proponent of free
trade with Cuba as as an anti regime
right
why would not specify but but not as
something that's you know I Castro as a
great guys now I should trade with him
where where do we stand with that and
has the Obama administration taken us a
little bit forward on Cuba Paulo they
have they have I was able to pass
legislation early in my career in
Washington mm - I think 2003 to prohibit
funding for enforcing the travel ban and
that's what I've been mostly concerned
about is a travel ban just the law that
prohibits Americans from being able to
travel to Cuba I've always thought that
just as silly the whole trade embargo
was silly frankly but travel ban chief
among it I could never get President
Bush to sign that kind of legislation so
twice it was removed before he would
sign it but President Obama has
liberalized and the travel requirements
and so Cuban Americans for example can
travel that will as much as they want
and so you have some three to four
400,000 visits to Cuba just in the past
year mostly Cuban Americans that's a
good thing that's a great thing to the
extent that it's possible in a communist
system more Cubans now are living kind
of outside of the state if you will and
be more economically independent than
they were before and that's a good thing
but but we still don't have the ability
of the average American to just pick up
and say I want to travel to Cuba you
have to go in and get a license and
either religious license you've had a
Tyrian license some educational license
and just doesn't make any sense at all
that's from the US for the USD that's
right these these these prohibitions
these sanctions are not on Cuba
they're on Americans and that's what
makes it so
and we have all this talk today about
Americans if the Republican Party is
becoming more isolationist because a lot
of Republicans don't want to intervene
in Libya and I always say who's
isolationist here who wants to prohibit
Americans from traveling to Cuba for
crying out loud
but you know if we lifted our travel
restrictions on Americans traveling to
Cuba
the next day I'm quite confident that
the Castro regime would impose some of
their own restrictions because they want
the revenue they don't want the
influence that comes with travel but if
somebody's going to limit my travel it
should be a communist knot not my own
government and that's that's how I feel
I other stuff that happened in the
during the long period of Republican
ascendancy was the Patriot Act right
where we have you know we've gone
through many different sunset revisions
over and over and everything seems to
keep coming back do we have any hope of
whittling back USA PATRIOT in a serious
way well we have in some way so we when
when the initial proposal came from the
Bush administration myself Ron Paul
Bobby Scott Bob Barr a lot of us sat
down and said you know what do we really
need and what can we take away and of
some 50 some proposals we whittled it
down to less than 20 and so we made some
headway from the beginning and then the
provisions that were troublesome we
sunset it and so we revisited them a few
times since I still have misgivings
about some of the things related to the
Patriot Act the National Security
Letters for example that just allow
government to get information from
businesses without the required warrants
I had trouble with the library provision
for example and access to public records
that individuals get and so I inserted
language or added amendments during the
last sunset that moved that up the chain
that would require the director of the
FBI to sign-off personally on these
things and so we've been able to attach
some some amendments and some protection
as we've gone along and we've been able
to sunset these provisions and we
revisit them it's kind of a it's an
uneasy balance as you go along and when
you meet with the intelligence community
they'll certainly tell you that these
provisions some of these have been very
useful and have maybe kept us safe in
certain situations and it's difficult to
talk about some of those publicly but
but it will always be a balancing act as
we go along balancing civil liberties
with the necessary tools that they need
but I've been convinced over the years
that the administration whether it's
Republican or Democrat will always seek
the maximum a number of tools and it's
up to Congress to go in and ensure that
civil liberties are protected and we've
tried and perhaps we can do a little
better job
I got a prior a little bit when you're
meeting with security types and they're
you know making the case for what how
such and such you know unraveled
whatever how much of that is backed up
by evidence and how much is take our
word for it now you have some of both
but but some of it can be backed up some
of it for example you know on these
library provisions and other things you
can actually ask them how many times was
this power of this Authority that you
have invoked and they have to tell you
and I mean there's always a possibility
that they don't tell you everything that
they're required to but I guess you just
have to assume that they will but on
some things you don't know if simply the
deterrent value of the ability to
attract all mobile devices or to have
roving wiretap or other things keeps
people who would do us harm from doing
so and that's difficult to quantify
right but you you have a lot of members
of Congress who are who take this very
seriously and are pushing I've been in
those meetings I've heard the questions
or asked some have been uncomfortable
for those in the intelligence community
but like I say we try to strike a
balance and we try to because technology
and
progresses so much you have to sunset
some of these provisions and revisit
them every few years to see what you're
doing
you mentioned isolationism are we how
much of the issue here is that there's a
new administration and there's a you
know there's some sort of
non-interventionism of convenience and
how much are we talking about defining
isolationism down because you know at
this point it's if you don't want to
have an undeclared open-ended bombing
campaign against the country that hasn't
done anything to us at least since 1989
that makes you an isolationist well I
think it's the latter
I think we've defined it a different way
we talk about we always invoke Ronald
Reagan and as a great man who understood
that you need to be engaged
internationally he did but he also
pulled out of Lebanon when he realized
that you know our presence there was
simply putting ourselves at danger and
that the that the benefits weren't great
enough so I think it's been defined
differently now I I don't consider
myself an isolationist at all but I
don't think it was right for us to
engage in Libya I don't think that the
benefits outweigh the costs I don't
think that makes me an isolationist
you're running for the Senate yes what
do you think of the two senators that
are with Arizona has right now I am a
politician I'm never gonna say thanks
let me just say with regard to Jon Kyl
whom I hope to replace to watch him
stand up and retire with his wife
standing by his side and without a
scandal
without Eddie now he's provided what I
consider stellar service over a couple
of decades and he's at the top of his
game as well in terms of power and
influence to see somebody like that just
walk away and it doesn't happen often in
Washington and it doesn't happen often
that we walk away while people are still
applauding and then that's certainly the
case with Jon Kyl and and so I I'm sorry
to see him go but Senate seats in
Arizona
come along with the frequency open
Senate seats with a frequency of
Halley's Comet I thank ya there Arizona
has been a state for a hundred years now
or just shy of a hundred and we've only
had 12 US senators and so the stars were
aligned as well as they could be and and
we announced just a few days after john
kyle announced that he would retire
immigration figures heavily in arizona
politics it's the home of America's
toughest Sheriff it's you know we've
seen the laws and so forth what's what's
going on there why is Arizona different
from New Mexico or Texas or Southern
California even what you've seen over
the past decade I mean I grew up in
northern Arizona I grew up on a ranch in
a farm we used labor from from Mexico
and south of the border but at that time
typically people would come work in
Arizona return home for the seasons for
birthdays for anniversaries whatever
because they could and it was a circular
pattern of migration over the past
couple of decades that circular pattern
has become a settled pattern or if
people cross once bring their families
and stay and then those costs are borne
by Arizonans and and we feel it we feel
the brunt of it more than the federal
government does because we pay a big
share of the cost and also the the
nature of the border itself has changed
as well and this is more more recent
phenomenon just over the past few years
it used to be there was the exception to
the rule if somebody crossing the border
was tied to drug smuggling or human
smuggling virtually all of them were
coming across to to do work in the
fields or in the hospitality industry or
construction industry and to work but
now because it's so expensive and
dangerous to cross the border virtually
everyone that crosses hires a human
smuggler and because it's so expensive
an increasing number have to carry drugs
to less than the cost of their passage
and so the border itself has become much
more dangerous you've had a rancher
killed there last year you have armed
convoys coming across the border often
in the rural areas and so the
the net effect down near the border for
the landholders and others has just been
a big change and and that's reflected in
in politics as well whereas you know
we've all wanted and I believe still
ultimately you'll need a comprehensive
solution to this problem that has a
temporary worker plan and some mechanism
to deal with those who are here
illegally and terior enforcement until
we get better security on the border
nobody's going to trust the federal
government to move ahead on any of the
other items why does it never occur to
anybody that the border becomes less
secure the more it's policed I mean you
know as the border has become harder to
get across and as you mentioned you have
to hire coyotes or whatever right that
that has actually stopped the circular
migration not you were just talking
about I and I I've always I've always
felt that the best way to secure the
border is have to have a legal framework
for people to come and go and then you
know your resources can be deployed
against those who are doing nefarious
things on the border and if we could
return to a time like when I grew up
where there was that circular pattern
that would be one thing but I think with
the threats today with terrorism and and
whatever else I just don't think that we
can return there to have an open border
like that just does not make sense for
our for our security you know you grew
up in northern Arizona in a place where
the Mormon Church was very active and
you're one of the Mormon serving and in
office we're and we're in an interesting
presidential field right now where there
you know we have a record number of
Mormons and a record number of small
government conservatives running so how
does that fit in has it ever affected
you do you think in your own you know
career no I mean from Arizona there's
been a number of Mormon legislators at
the state level and a state legislature
or well-respected individuals and I've
been fortunate to follow in their
footsteps and
the Arizona has a greater percentage of
Mormons and a lot of states perhaps but
nationwide looking at the situation it
may not be a plus right now in some
southern states to be a Mormon candidate
but I don't think it's a disqualifier
anywhere and so I think that you know
the candidacy of Mitt Romney last time
and the fact that you have Harry Reid a
very prominent Democrat Mormon on one
side and Mitt Romney John Huntsman and
others on the other side it lets people
know that there's little to fear there
sure I is is the issue overblown to
remember there was a poll a few years
ago claiming that it was you know uh
being a Mormon was a bigger liability
than I forget what the other with the
other liability which word also not
liabilities it was like being a minority
being a woman supply guy yeah is is that
Amy do we make too much of that yes I
think so somebody pointed out there was
a recent poll that said there's still
about 25 percent the population it's
uncomfortable voting for a Mormon but
it's also been pointed out that that
figure was higher for those who felt
uncomfortable voting for Catholic just
prior to john f kennedy's election so i
am not sure that those polls capture the
real feelings and particularly in a year
like this with the economy so so poor if
you have somebody that that is a great
candidate and every other respect i
think a lot of people worry less about
where they go to church sure could you
talk a little bit about the role of
religion in public life though and the
way you know how it informs your own
thinking and certainly i always it
always seemed like orrin hatch was
somebody who you could always he was
often off the reservation with the
republicans in terms of tolerance you
know on religious issues and it seemed
to me that was specifically because you
know you're coming from a place where
everybody views you as something you
know that yes your own belief is
something odd and the
kind of internalize that I don't know I
think everyone's religion and informs
their values and it's difficult to to
decide what where one ends and the other
begins without getting into somebody's
head or their heart so I don't know how
to answer that I'm my own religion
I assume like everyone else does inform
my values but I don't think in a way
that that makes anyone uncomfortable
that's not been my experience I've not
faced any many incidents where people
have been uncomfortable that way well
you're going ahead with the Senate run
your own seat is hotly contested so what
happens next and where should what do
you think we should be looking at in the
complexion of the House and the Senate
over the next couple of years well we
have a good opportunity as Republicans
now Democrats had a very good year in
2006 both in the House and the Senate in
the Senate that means they have a lot of
seats to defend in 2012 in fact 23 of
the 33 seats our Democrat seats so I
think we just need a net pickup of four
as Republicans and and I I think we can
do it and I think we're going to need to
regardless of who holds the White House
and I obviously is a Republican or a
Republican in that seat but when you
look at the challenges this country is
facing so many of them won't be solved
just by putting a Republican in the
White House we really need a Republican
Senate as well speak specifically about
regulations the federal agencies I mean
these agencies are out of control we've
seen anything over the past several
months it's these agencies whether it's
the EPA whether that's you know the
financial regulations that have been
imposed these agencies just moving as if
they need no congressional authority and
when you look at things that stifle the
economy it's not just tax rates it's
regulation and we've got to get a handle
on that and so whether or not we have a
Republican in the White House if we can
control
house in the Senate we can have a huge
impact on where these agencies go what
they regulate what they don't and and
that's what this economy really needs
you what do you think of the argument
that divided government is is the friend
of people who don't want the government
to keep growing that's if you look back
in history divided government has been
good government if you want limited
government and I think you can find more
instances of that then you know unified
government if you will producing that
outcome
so yeah III I think that when you look
at the 90s for example we started to
balance budgets we had a good period of
free trade and and good economics
without having a Republican in the White
House we can do that again like I said
I'm gonna try for to control every
chamber and hope we behave differently
next time but yeah divided government is
often very good government terrific well
thank you very much for joining us thank
you for having me
you